pour ce nouveau numéro nous allons nous
mettre en lien avec le royaume des morts
mais avant tout les Suisses savez-vous
ce que signifie
le nom de cesser de vivre
bien avançons je vais désormais choisir
quelqu'un au hasard dans ce public afin
de me mettre en lien avec lui de ce pas
vous monsieur par exemple monsieur
jurez-vous devant tous les cantons
suisses que nous ne sommes jamais
rencontrés jamais vu et que je ne vous
ai pas équipé d'un micro non filaire
il confirme
alors connaissez-vous une personne morte
qui définirait le caractère de Jacques
votre père mort
nous avons plusieurs informations à
disposition le père de Pierre-Alain Jack
il est malheureusement décédé et avait
un caractère un tout petit peu
alcoolique
nous allons donc désormais laisser
Cédric rentrer en contact avec l'entité
de Jack et le pénétrer ou alors plutôt
laisser Jacques le pénétrer
[Musique]
un problème d'interférence Cédric il
s'agit ici du président de la République
française Jacques Chirac ça dépend le
bon Jack allez on se reconcentre et on y
retourne let's go
pénétré par une personne qui fait de
très mauvaise limitations allez on
essaie une dernière fois de se connecter
au père de Pierre Alain un petit peu
alcoolique et décédé l'alcool
j'arrive pas à me connecter à son père
et on s'en fout on est devant des fils
en fait tu inventes d'accord
je vais très bien alors ne t'inquiète
pas et tu as vu j'ai le bois plus une
goutte d'alcool je ne suis pas bourré
bien merci pour cette conversation avec
l'au-delà allez bon deuil pierre Alan
vous avez été mentalisé et ça c'est